The mom of that Chiefs player
who made that stupid fucking commencement speech.
She was a physicist.
He wasn't raised by a homemaker.
He just thought this grandiose idea of all on his own.
And this is just another little bit of evidence for me
and my little personal research project
that these men who want traditional wives
are really just hurt by their mom.
Their mom didn't make them the center of their fucking universe.
They didn't understand how to cope with that.
So they found a woman that would.
You're gonna be the mommy that I never had.
You're gonna be the mommy that don't send me hand and foot,
make sure I have warm cookies when I come home from school.
And make sure that my favorite socks and underwear
are clean for my next game. And.
And then they get to fuck them.
It's like this weird Freudian fucked up world that they want to create.
So stay the fuck away from them.
Choose! Choose the bear!